hello there you're watching the press
preview it's a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive well it's
time to see what's making the headlines
with the daily mirror columnist susie
boniface and the former government
special
mo hussein evening to both of you they
will be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's have a look to
see what is on some of those front pages
are the theme the same on nearly all of
them the mirror reports on the
developing situation in afghanistan
covering the suicide bomb that detonated
on thursday in kabul
on that same story the express has the
headline two brits killed waiting for
freedom the telegraph quotes the prime
minister saying he feels a great sense
of regret that around eleven hundred
afghans who served alongside british
forces are unlikely to make it out of
the country
britain risks the biggest hostage crisis
in history that is according to the
daily mail
and the eye declares thousands abandoned
to the taliban the guardian has a very
similar headline
and the times hears washington is
planning retaliatory attacks on is
forces inside afghanistan
in other news the financial times says
that ministers have called on businesses
to hire uk-based workers that's after
furlough and strict immigration rules
have resulted in a chronic shortage of
lorry drivers
and the manchester evening news welcomes
what it calls the sensational return of
the footballer cristiano ronaldo to man
united with this headline
back home
well while the star deems it the second
coming of cristiano
well as promised we are joined this
evening uh by susie bonneyface and uh mo
hussein uh evening to both of you it's
been a hard week hasn't it of news and
those front pages really bear out what
the world has been witnessing we're
going to talk first about the front page
of the daily mail as susie coming to you
it's referencing there's more than a
thousand people likely to be left by the
uk government in afghanistan who we
couldn't get out in time and saying that
britain risks the biggest hostage crisis
in its history
yeah and it's worth bringing mine that's
sort of 1100 or so people
would is the equivalent of two or three
uh transport planes that's just how
we were to
getting everybody out who needed to be
out these are also just the ones that
the mod
know about or will admit to there may
well be others
um who aren't going to get it across
either now one of the things that um the
government and various people in cabinet
and so on are saying is well the next
best thing that anyone who's in
afghanistan could do is get themselves
to a refugee camp head for the borders
guys and get to refugee camp and you can
apply for a visa there now the distance
from kabul to the nearest city in
pakistan uh peshawar is about 200 miles
which is about the same as london to
manchester and
if you can imagine setting out from
london with your entire family on foot
through
war zones
and imagine you're going past repeated
roadblocks thrown up fundamentalist
lunatics who want to enslave your
children rape your wife and shoot you in
the head and ask yourself if you feel
like walking from manchester to london
or the other way around you're not doing
it just saying it's it's just go to a
refugee camp and apply through the visa
process there it's not a solution
refugee camps anyone who's been in them
will tell you i riddled with disease and
crime uh in this part of the world with
terror recruiters with all those who
can't operate in
um within pakistan or afghanistan
they're the there's fairly lawless
places and they're not the best place in
the world we're sending people
especially when we've got responsibility
to get out the fact that we've left
those people on is utterly shameful yeah
i mean the prime minister mo
acknowledges that he's got an obligation
he says he's going to shift heaven and
earth to get them out i mean
it doesn't appear to have been confirmed
that france is stopping its evacuation
flights do you think you should keep
them going a little longer
i think you should i think we owe a real
debt to these people who have been
working alongside our troops and our
officials over the last 20 years i just
don't think it's good enough to
just say the last thousand and it's
probably more susie says cannot uh make
it through just because of a
self-imposed deadline by the u.s
government it is hard it's hard for the
uk to do this uh alone but maybe with
other countries we could uh try and get
a few more planes out there because the
alternative is that we are leaving these
people
to
the taliban and to the dehumanizing
inhumane treatment from them and we're
in a really strange position now because
a lot of uh references to the taliban as
the new government or somehow our
security partners i found it hugely
ironic when the taliban themselves
spoke about the suicide attack attack
yesterday and condemned it when they
themselves have committed so many of
these and there are real questions
around
how these people who committed the
attack isis k as they called did so
because they were let out of the prisons
by the taliban themselves so um we are
we are leaving these people to the hands
of a very oppressive
medieval regime and i do think we need
to do everything we can it's fine saying
you'll move heaven and earth but what
are we actually going to do to help
these people yeah i means echoed as well
isn't it susie on the front page of the
telegraph talking about that the prime
minister says it's his great regret that
he has to leave people behind there is
talk of an imminent uh potential second
terror attack in kabul uh what do you
think does he have a choice
i think that headline would be more
accurate if it said pm speaks of great
regret at leaving brits behind which is
who they are they're not um foreign
nationals many of them either work for
us they are british they're related to
brits and they've certainly got a very
strong right to be british if they're
not already i think and the prime
minister within that copy actually
refers to the fact that many of the 1100
are uk nationals all right it's not
afghans left behind it's brits left
behind and that's what um that headline
completely fails to report on properly
but one of the things that's really
interesting you know is that um this
lots of the talk has been going on about
well no one knew always happened in a
rush
and you know this was agreed in february
2020 by donald trump's administration
the pull-out and it was going to be
happening in may it was going to happen
much sooner than this when joe biden
took over in january he set the date
moved it back and said it was going to
be september
and france began evacuating their afghan
um connections in april i think it was i
saw today now in july joe biden changed
his mind and said they'd be leaving in
august now that's very very quick and
it's far too rapid but
britain has known
for more than a year this was coming
down the tracks the actual date of
departure has switched about a bit but
we knew and in march on march the 31st
i was just reading actually the home
office published guidance on the afghan
relocation scheme for interpreters and
that included um
saying that uh you know that it wouldn't
apply to contractors people who were
contracted by somebody else but not
directly employed by the uk government
it said that it wouldn't apply to people
who hadn't worked for the government for
more than 12 months you had to work for
the uk government for 12 months to apply
so if you were there for 11 months and
three weeks and just as likely to be
killed you still weren't going to get in
on the scheme uh there's possibility of
taking dna tests and it said in the
guidance that it could take somewhat in
two four or more weeks for decisions to
be made that was back in march so
between march and august the 18th when
the government suddenly realized it had
to get um its afghan interpretations out
you know the home office sat in its
hands and did nothing this is not just
susie
let me bring in mo here as somebody
who's worked um you know very much in
the inner workings of whitehall i mean
governments know don't they whether it's
us or british government that they also
have their domestic will primarily have
their domestic audience to play to so
it's when you get headlines that what we
see on the front page of the daily
express two brits killed waiting for
freedom that it it does come home
yeah i think that's a very very fair
point headlines like this do to be on
action and do you get people to do
things i think it does point to
an element of surprise there probably
was some kind of calculation that
perhaps
the biden administration would take a
slightly different approach and perhaps
the behind the scenes negotiations from
all the other countries would change
minds clearly that hasn't worked and
there has been an overall failure of
planning and a failure of intelligence
and you have a situation now where the
very thing that biden was talking about
avoiding you know ending these forever
wars preventing more american fatalities
and now british fatalities unfortunately
this is exactly what we are seeing and
he's now having to commit to more
military operations uh there rather than
than less so in terms of planning in
terms of execution this has been a
dismal failure and i don't think this is
really about never leaving it's not a
binary choice but it's about how you
leave and doing it in a way that you
avoided this
complete and utter mess and the human
cost which is the worst part yeah well
we don't have time before the break but
i do just want to show our viewers this
double spread
inside the mirror simply says about that
terror attack in kabul killed by cowards
a double page spread there talking about
the growing threat to the people
remaining in afghanistan
from isis k a group that we haven't
heard much about but i'm sure we'll be
hearing plenty more about them in the
days and weeks coming one of the few
papers to actually have a story
featuring on its front page other than
afghanistan susie is the ft uh so
talking about the
business secretary uh is called to hire
uk workers referencing the shortage
we've seen in hauliers which has
resulted in uh
the run on certain food products in the
supermarkets
yes and i just want to stop for a moment
and think of the fact this is a guy
who's in government right he's making
really important decisions about how our
country's run and he has uh said that we
can supply the uh
the failure of not having enough hgv
drivers by just uh paying more and
recruiting british people to be hgv
drivers now that would be great if uh
you know the average lorry driver is
over 45 because it's a really difficult
job that involves long hours perhaps 15
hours a day being a long way away from
your family it doesn't suit people who
are younger
an awful lot of our unemployed people in
this country at the moment are younger
people um six percent of all jobs in
june this year were actually people who
were aged 18 to 24 and they were
furloughed um there's 406 000 people
under 25 who are unemployed you can't
just fix the hgv driver problem telling
younger people to get an htv license
it's not going to work plus it raises
the cost of food it raises the cost of
salaries throughout the supply chain
it's not a simple fix is it i mean what
do you think is what's he going to have
to do and should introduce laksa rules
on immigration
yeah well this is really about the
government trying to make more use of
the post-brexit immigration rules and
the powers that they now have and also
there's a real awareness in government
that the follow scheme ends at the end
of september and there are still two
million people or so who are on a full
or partial furlough and so jobs will
need to exist for these people
to
go on to and for us to avoid this
massive spike in unemployment which the
government has been avoiding so far by
continuing the photo scheme i don't
think ministers telling people what jobs
that they should go into ever really
works out well but the thinking behind
it is to avoid this cliffhanger it's not
gonna it's not gonna go down well is it